in 1984 little Bastian bux watched as
the unforgettable heroes from the
neverending story battled against the
nothing to save a kingdom from certain
doom the fantasy family film still
resonates but what's become of its
actors here's what the cast of the
neverending story looks like today
Barrett Oliver former child star Barrett
Oliver got his big Hollywood break by
playing our heroic reader Bastian bux
in the neverending story he went on to
claim starring roles in Tim Burton's
1984 short film Frankenweenie 1985 s
family sci-fi film Darrell and Ron
Howard's cocoon in 1985 Oliver told
Starlog I don't regret that I decided to
become an actor besides if I don't like
it at anytime I can stop and in 1989 he
did just that
Oliver is now a photographic historian
who literally wrote the book on the
Woodbury type printing process of the
19th century he briefly returned to the
front of the camera in 2007 when he
starred in a short documentary about his
craft called in the usual manner Noah
Hathaway Atreyu was something of a
comeback kid in the neverending story he
endured the depressing death of his
horse and still managed to battle back
existential forces of destruction his
real-life counterpart Noah Hathaway
seems to share that resilience the actor
has returned to Hollywood after nearly
20 years away from the spotlight before
the neverending story Hathaways credits
included 1978's Battlestar Galactica as
well as appearances on many popular
shows like Mork & Mindy chips and
Laverne & Shirley he quit the business
after starring in 1986 his troll because
as he told the News Tribune he just
wanted to drop off the radar and be a
regular human being for a while after
his career as a child star Hathaway
worked in finance and tattoo artistry
and decided to return to show business
in 2012 when he landed a role in sushi
girl and began writing his own
screenplays Tami's drona the childlike
Empress had no screen experience to
speak of when she nabbed the iconic role
in the neverending story
Tammy's drone Ark explained a / film
that she was accidentally spotted by a
casting agent who arrived for lunch
early drone Ark almost completely
disappeared from the screen to focus on
professional dancing which she employed
in a 2008 foreign language TV musical
where she played a dancing doll now she
runs her own company in New York
and her decision to pursue a mostly non
Hollywood Life was intentional saying I
love dancing and acting equally and when
we were thrown a lot of these odd
scripts we just looked at each other and
said we're not going to play this game
right I made a decision that I would
throw myself into dance and then if I
really missed acting I returned to it as
an adult so that's what I did and I
ended up dancing from 20 years
professionally in New York she did end
up frequenting the stage for several
years and helped develop the paper canoe
Theatre Company when she started to miss
the acting business deployed the actor
who played teeny weeny has had a long
and fruitful career in show business the
Kenya born deep Roy might actually be
better known for his parts and other TV
and film roles like mr. sin and Doctor
Who mr. soggy bottom and big fish the
old balloon bus' and Tim burns Charlie
in the Chocolate Factory or Kinser in
the Star Trek films although Roy was
almost a decade into his career before
he starred in the neverending story it
was one of his first big film roles he's
pretty much been acting consistently
since 1976 and unlike his co-stars he
shows no signs of stopping
Tilo propanone german actor Tilo partner
would hardly be recognizable those who
saw him in the neverending stories since
so much makeup work went into becoming
his character the night hop
however broke nur has been acting in
films and television for decades and has
over 200 credits to his name starting
all the way back in the late 60s most of
his work has been in Europe and the
neverending story was no exception as it
was filmed primarily in director
Wolfgang Petersen's native West Germany
Gerald McRaney the role of bastions dad
in the neverending story was brief but
actor Gerald McRaney has enjoyed a lot
more screen time in his subsequent
projects he developed a great small
screen resume before landing the small
supporting role in the movie and he's
since continued to thrive on television
most notably he started in Simon and
Simon for eight seasons before becoming
the titular father character in the 1989
sitcom major dad he also enjoyed regular
roles on Deadwood Jericho house of cards
and in 2016 appeared as a part of the
ensemble cast of the NBC drama this is
us alan oppenheimer
little friends the voice actor
responsible for most of the neverending
stories most memorable non-human
characters including the rock fighter
Falkor and Gamora was alan oppenheimer
who's had an illustrious career in front
of the mic and the camera
his screen appearance credits include an
emmy nominated guest role on Murphy
Brown but his voice credits are
practically never-ending he's perhaps
best known for his work on filmation's
version of the Ghostbusters and
transformers and he-man and the Masters
of the Universe
[Music]
even with all those amazing credits
he'll always be old Falkor does thanks
for watching if you're looking for
another channel exploring cool topics
and unusual and super entertaining ways
then go check out wisecrack they're a
collective of comedians academics
filmmakers and artists who are super
curious about the world around us
wisecrack releases addictive new videos
every week click here to visit their
channel page and subscribe one of our
favorites is their video about the
hidden meaning in Disney's frozen so go
subscribe to wisecrack and tell them
looper ascension
[Music]